hello everyone and welcome back to the
official random World Championship we
are here with a very nice game it's
their second game of the match Magnus
Carlson versus Hikaru Nakamura this is
basically Neo versus Morpheus when two
of them play uh we drop whatever we are
doing and we watch it regardless of what
they are doing they can be throwing
darts you know playing uh uh cards at
the beach doesn't really matter we will
watch it as they have so much history
between them and so much a rivalry uh
the games are always incredibly exciting
and I think they they respect each other
uh well to to to a great extent now
let's check it out it's the second game
of their match first game ended in a
draw and it was quite a wild one but
this one it's uh just uh crazy what
happened so Magnus with the white pieces
and uh for some reason uh sorry magnus's
uh magnus's rating is not updated I have
no idea why
sometimes this happens with my interface
so give me just a second
uh there we go
yeah I updated hikarus I just forgot to
update the Magnus then it's going to be
weird you guys will be okay what kind of
a rating is this and then I'm gonna have
to answer so it's better to just fix it
so there we have it Magnus is 2856 even
though this is classical rating I don't
think they they
um I have official random ratings yet
but they should have them at some point
I mean if it's going to be a thing but
okay Magnus has the white pieces and he
opens with the strongest move in certain
positions and that is Pawn to B4 and
Hikaru plays Ponte D5 with the colors
reversed first game where Hikaru had the
white piece Hikaru also pushed the B
Pawn but Magnus replied with the G5 I
don't know if you've seen the game if
you haven't do check it out it seems
like Magnus is blundering a full Bishop
here but actually if if the bishop is
captured then you play Knight to F6 you
attack the queen and after Queen G7 you
attack the queen again and after Queen
H6 it seems like the queen can escape
but now you play D5 you take away the h
3 Square from the queen and next move
you win the queen will Rook the G6 so it
would be a very very unfortunate to do
something like this but okay after B4 we
have D5 by Hikaru uh a pawn to G3 and
now Pawn to C6 with Bishop to G2 uh
Knight to F6 and now Pawn to A4 so
putting pieces on optimal squares Magnus
grabbing a lot of space here on the
queen Side Pawn to G6 with Knight to F3
uh freeing up the square for for the
white king the castle King side Knight
to A6 and now Magnus first place Bishop
to A3 and it's a very nasty idea uh
thing is that uh if Hikaru castles now
which of course he would very much want
the B5 just wins the game for Magnus the
Knight is saying and also Bishop
captures on E7 is a threat uh not not a
good way inside to handle this so
instead after Bishop A3 Knights to E4 by
Hikaru now it's uh of course the White
Queen is hanging we have Queen to A2 and
now Knights the D6 so now you've blocked
the The Bishop's path to the E7 Pawn so
D3 by Magnus and now both players Castle
King side so castles castles and now uh
Hikaru was probably tired of calculating
B5 every move so he just pushes B5
himself uh Queen to B3 by Magnus we have
B characters on a for Queen captures and
knock winter B7
we have C3 by Magnus and now Bishop to
D7 preparing to open up a discovery on
the White Queen so Queen back to C2 and
now Rook the C8 we have Pawn to D4 uh
stopping the the bishop here and also
gaining more control over the C5 Square
we have Knight the C7 re-maneuvering the
Knight over to B5 and Knight B to D2 uh
we have Knight seat the B5 now attacking
the bishop and just the bishop back the
B2 by Magnus Bishop to F5 attacking the
queen and now Queen to B3 and now Hikaru
just sacrifices a pawn with A5 for a lot
of activity he wants to put the rokanai
the other rook and B8 and he's gonna
reclaim the pawn eventually so Magnus
captures that b captures an A5 and now
Queen C7 attacks the pawn Magnus defends
the pawn queen to A4 now Rook to A8 we
have Rook to A1 adds another Defender to
the pawn and Rook F to B8 uh now this is
uh although usually something you want
to do especially when you have your
Bishop here your Rooks controlling the
the a file the B file something like for
example you would have a benko Gambit
type compensation but uh here maybe just
a doubling immediately on the a file and
going after the pawn would have been a
bit more sound but maybe Hikaru is
playing this uh you know for some long
long term Advantage so okay Rook F to C1
by Magnus and now Knight to E4 yeah
putting pressure on the Knight here also
putting pressure on the C3 Pawn uh
Magnus traits we have captures captures
and now comes Knight to D2
here there is a very very specific
engine move that is on the C4 uh now of
course if you capture just real captures
nothing happens but the real idea is
that after Knight the D6 opening up a
discovery towards the bishop you can
just play C5 that's the point and you've
improved your Pawn structure from the
pawn being on C3 Pawn being now on C5
and you can't really trade if you trade
just captures and now you've opened up
wise paths to the C6 pawn and if you
don't what do you what you play you can
move the Knight back Knight the B5 or
Knight C4 and then another problem just
Rook day two you're gonna add a Defender
here you're gonna a triple up on the a
file you keep the a pawn and you know
life is just good so one possibility
yeah from a good friend D engine but
okay Magnus goes Knight to D2 he offers
a trade of light Square Bishops we have
captures captures and now hikar says all
right you didn't want to do it so I'm
gonna do it pawn to C5 with the idea of
advancing the pawn to C4 we have rooked
the C2 and Now Pawn to C4 we have Knight
to F3 by Magnus now with more control
over the E5 square and now Knight the A7
Hikaru wants to
re-maneuver the Knight and now Magnus
could go for something like a bishop to
C1 to F4 to grab hold of this diagonal
but he goes Bishop to A3 he wants to
play Bishop C5 and then put the bishop
on B6 which would be excellent for him
but now as they are both very low on
time and notice that they have to play
30 moves uh for the first 25 minutes
that they have and only then are they
granted additional five minutes plus
they get increment after every move is
played after move 30 but this move 27
three more moves need to be played and
they are very very low on time so here
he carves strikes in the center with
Pawn to E5 with d captures on E5 by
Magnus and the bishop characters on E5
seems like a shame to give up such a
nice Bishop but it really wasn't doing
all that much on h8 especially with a
closed position like this so here Knight
captures an E5 you could also play Rook
to D1 this is a winning for for Magnus
but again such a weird move to play
point is that after Rook to D1 uh
there's uh not all the that much for you
to do the pawn is hanging If you defend
it let's say Rook to B5 you also put
pressure on the A5 Pawn there's a bishop
B4 now you're defending everything here
and you're just gonna well depends on
what the bishop does you're either gonna
capture it and then play Rook to D4 Rook
to D2 put pressure on the D pawn and
enjoy your past a pawn or the bishop
moves and then you can double up uh in a
different fashion but all in all it will
be winning for white but uh you know a
few more moves uh need to be played
until time control is reached so Magnus
plays Knight captures on E5 we have
Queen characters on E5 and now Bishop to
C5 so Magnus continues with his plan he
will also uh at some point maybe put a
bishop on D4 maybe on B6 depending on
what Hikaru plays and here he carries
all that time Hikaru spent playing
puzzle rush really pays off as Hikaru
sets up the dirtiest of Tricks Hikaru
plays Rook the B3 and this does not only
attack the C3 Pawn this also does
something else but you guys will be
there there to see what it is I'm not
going to tell you in case some of you
haven't seen the actual game here Magnus
has to be very very careful but he
pushes A6 which is of course something
you want to do once you've uh uh you
know removed all of the danger from the
board but not at this particular moment
because now A6 blunders the game
completely so feel free to pause the
video and try to see what Magnus missed
win the game for Hikaru while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that by
playing Rook the B3 Hikaru actually
disconnected the Queen's defense of the
rook and C2 and now the Rook is up for
grabs so he just plays Queen to e for
check and he uh Forks the king and the
Rock so beautifully played by Hikaru
Magnus saw this and as usual he was
disgusted with himself so
congratulations to everyone who found
this you've just won a full Rook from
Magnus Carlsen so King the G1 Magnus
could resigned here but of course there
is some counter play and the Magnus
finds incredible counter play here so
King G1 Queen captures on C2 he is down
a full Rook but look at this queen to D7
attacking the uh the uh Knight here now
how do you how do you defend the knight
uh can you just move the Knight back
let's say you go knight uh Knight a B5
then Queen captures on D5 grabs the pawn
attacks The Rook here it's not uh it's
not great so it's instead after Queen to
D7 Hikaru just plays Rook the B1 with
Trek Rook captures Queen captures with
check King G2 and now Queen B5 Hikaru
finds very interesting counter play and
now comes Queen to B7 attacking the the
queen and duruk and okay Hikaru trades
Queen captures Pawn captures and now
from being down a full Rook Magnus will
win the Knight on A7 and he will only be
down in exchange Rook to B8 Bishop
captures an A7 Rook capture Sun B7 and
now Bishop to D4 so it's Five Pawns each
Hikaru has a rook Magnus has a bishop uh
Ken Magnus hold this let's see how the
game went Ponte uh sorry the first king
to f8 Hikaru of course starts bringing
the king into the game and now Magnus
has to create some sort of a fortress
the problem is Magnus does not believe
in fortresses and uh probably because he
doesn't believe in fortresses also
doesn't believe that he is capable of
creating a fortress but he will of
course try upon the G4 King 7 we have
Pawn to G5 okay grabbing all the key
squares on the king side Hikaru just
continues King E6 we have Pawn to F3 now
comes Rook to B1 on to E3 we have King
to D6 with King to G3 now comes King to
C6 what is Hikaru doing uh bring that
King all the way to the queen side King
to F4 Hikaru plays Rook the F1 now
putting pressure on the F3 Pawn uh and
here we have pawned the H4 by Magnus and
King the B5 by Hikaru and when Hikaru
played King to B5 it was in this
position unmove 46 that Magnus Carlsen
resigned to the game and with it their
mini match as their first game ended in
a draw second game was won by Hikaru so
Hikaru wins there uh their mini match
now why did Magnus resign so quickly
well he realized of course that Hikaru
knows what he is doing and that there is
no point in continuing this uh point is
that the black king will just travel all
the way to the E2 square and win the F3
pawn and then you just resign or you can
maybe prolong it a little bit let's say
you play something like this you allow
all of this to allow the king to get to
here but now okay you don't allow him to
go all the way to the pawn you you push
the pawn because now okay the black king
might be a bit too deep for example
captures now the F Pawn is pin so you
have to capture with the king the
problem is just Rook H1 now the H Pawn
will hang so there's even that you don't
really have anything if the bishop
defense then the C3 Pawn Falls so
whatever white plays you will win a pawn
create a pass pawn and then it's really
yeah impossible to hold
so yeah uh everything was was done well
Magnus played a very very very uh high
profile game but uh here after he I mean
he he probably just thought that okay
Hikaru player looked at B3 he's being
sneaky he wants to grab the C3 Pawn but
no Hikaru actually
uh what he did was much much dirtier and
much much sneakier and sometimes you can
see that it pays off the uh to play
moves like that and Hikaru is the
absolute best in the world that playing
moves like that he just plays them so
fast crazy creates these little little
traps and you can see that even uh
Magnus can fall for it and the funniest
thing is uh after when he car played
Rook to B3 time control was already
reached Magnus was granted additional
time and he was granted increment but
then he just continued uh pushed A6 and
he fell apart
uh so yeah uh that's the game very
nicely played by Hikaru uh truly truly a
brilliant move this Rook to B3 I mean
what a move uh always look for moves
like these uh they will you know help
you win win uh great games and many
games
uh so I will also I will show at least
one more game from the first today so I
will only then show you the standings
because a lot has happened but stay
tuned for that
um it will be an interesting one uh so
yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Derek
Alex Williams Stephen Pryor uh uh
subramanian John uh sharkliff and um
treats for medo for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this fine
event until it finishes uh so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day